[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have once again
announced the games we'll be getting as
PS plus essential subscribers for the
month of May 2023 they'll be dropping on
May the 2nd it's not the greatest month
ever so please remember I don't pick the
games I just report them let's do this
grid Legends kicks off the month on both
PS4 and PS5 with over 130 tracks to race
on including real life circuits and new
city street tracks including Paris and
London grid Legends has over 100 cars to
drive from touring cars to off-road
trucks from drift cars to electric
vehicles the career mode is presented
with live-action cut scenes as if it was
a documentary on a sports channel and
it's a surprisingly good way to build a
story and see the faces of your Rivals
Legends brings back the Nemesis system
with one driver who is out and out your
enemy and a really cool addition sees
the ability to aggro drivers by bumping
into them too often they'll hold a
grudge and in future Races they will
Target you getting a side swipe at the
worst possible moment that all adds to
the unpredictability of races where
other drivers will regularly make
mistakes crash out have engine failures
causing panic inducing moments on track
a mode I was impressed by was the
multi-class races essentially cars of
different powers can be pitted together
in the same race but the better cars are
given a delayed start making it feel
like a game of cat and mouse as the laps
ticked down all in all grid Legends is a
solid arcade racer averaging 8 out of 10
by professional reviewers next up is the
Medieval Warfare mop chivalry 2 both on
the PS4 and PS5 a melee focused hack and
slash game that can be played in first
or third person with swords hammers
Macy's and axes to choose from with the
same basic three-directional swings
horizontal vertical and stab chain
together how you see fit this basic
approach makes being a new player less
daunting than other medieval fighting
games chivalry supports 64 players at
once in one mosh pit of action in Team
Deathmatch modes the Agatha Knight in
blue face off against the red of the
Mason order and since release another
faction was added to the game the
tenosian empire in team objective modes
one Army must break into another's
Castle destroying armaments on Route The
Defenders can win by keeping the
attackers at Bay and holding out as time
slowly ticks down and if you have anger
issues there's a 40 player free for all
brawl mode in which chairs rolling
pinned bread and even turkey legs can be
used as Weapons maybe we need to start
having a monthly meet up where we try
out these game modes chivalry 2 divides
characters into classes to quickly
select for the playstyle you desire it's
totally unrealistic but it can be fun at
every level of ability with a decent
number of cosmetic items to choose from
your character can look how you see fit
chivalry 2 had some impressive ratings
on launch day in 2021 averaging 8 out of
10 although the PS4 version is greatly
lower than the PS5 version if you trust
Metacritic finally another racing game
but not the kind you're thinking of on
PS4 we have descenders going downhill as
fast as you can on two wheels momentum
and the sheer speed it feels like when
playing this is the real appeal and on
top of that there are crazy air jumps
and intricate Corners to master wiping
out too many times and your run is over
there is something which sets this
downhill racer apart from the others it
has a roguelike element each time we
play a mutator is applied a risk reward
challenge for example additional Health
could be given to your Rider but to keep
it you must keep above 60 kilometers per
hour descenders is also a game that may
force you to break your controller
because a perfect run can be ruined by a
tiny muscle mistake on a thumbstick and
to add to all that each course is
procedurally generated so no track
should ever be the same so that's our
month how are you feeling about it happy
sad delighted mad please let me know in
the comments I'm Adam you're awesome
I'll see you next time